my father excuse me my father graduated
in 1962 from Howard University so
historically black college and he was
college roommates with Stokely
Carmichael which tells you a lot sort of
about who my dad is he's a very serious
you know black community black power
sort of advocate of the 60s my mother at
the same time graduated in nineteen
sixty four from Brigham Young University
group in the West and is a or was a
white Mormon so when they met in the
early 70s it was this kind of black
nationalist dad and this white Mormon
mom who met in seattle washington which
is where i was born when they were in
grad school so although i was raised in
the south it wasn't in a typical
southern family it was in a very unique
kind of interracial interesting family
so my father before he met my mother had
three children with an african-american
woman so my three oldest sibling's are
black in terms of both of their parents
being black my mother had been
previously married to a white man and
had one daughter who was white so in my
household there were three siblings who
both of their parents were black one
sibling who both of her parents were
white and then me who had one black and
one white parent so that means that from
very early on there were I mean from
from immediately even sort of in my
household there were different racial
identities people thinking and
understanding themselves within
different identities but of course also
all being brother and sisters which was
I don't know I suspect relatively unique
maybe Barack Obama also had that but
just sort of me and Barack that's the
one with that story so I would say very
early on but it didn't have a negative
connotation for me it just had an
awareness sort of like if you grew up
with a bunch of boys and girls in your
family you learn about boys and girls
well I grew up with black and white
people in my family so I had an early on
sense of black and white